[MUSIC PLAY]
PAUL SMURL: Technology is currently confusing our entire industry
and has accelerated over the past few years - with a move
from the traditional media and print based organization to one
which is a global digital media organization. "The New York
Times "is known for the highest quality
journalism on earth.
We have been in business for over 160 years.
People who use our programs get deeper
involved in the content therein.
They are more likely to return regularly, dig deeper
and finally becoming subscribers.
KATE HARRIS: We launched our first Android program in 2010.
So we were very early on that platform.
And since then, it's just been about growth.
And - over the past 2 years - it has exploded.
To build a successful Android product,
It is essential to have a team that really understands
how the platform works, living for the platform, what
obsessive about Android.
And we're very happy to have it at "The New York Times".
Android makes it really easy to build apps
intuitive to use.
It's also easy as a program developer or publisher
to build apps that use our own typography, the
program like the "The New York Times."
Integrated before our Play Billing,
took our subscription process about two minutes.
And we asked users for a series of forms
to fill in, all on their phone.
And now with Play Billing, because the user says
credit card or their Paypal information associated with their account,
can subscribe to "The New York Times"
with two taps.
Some of the typing features on Play Billing I love very much,
is, one, that our local currency billing
can be activated in more than 50 countries.
And, two, it was very easy to add a free trial.
With Play Invoicing we can increase
125% in subscription conversion realized.
PAUL SMURL: We did the sums.
We looked at the benefit, in terms of
incremental subscriptions will outweigh the
30% issue we pay to Google.
And that is indeed the case.
Android is an incredibly important platform for us.
It's one of our fastest growing platforms.
We consider our investment in Android as an essential one.
And with regard to our international growth ambitions,
Android was a necessary investment for us.
[MUSIC PLAY]